this week we're talking about a last a
file learning gke and bigquery
I'm Jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news earlier this year we
launched a last a file file service on
GCP a fully managed version of alasa
file integrated with Google cloud so
what's going to change with the intent
to acquire elasto file
cloud file storage is set to become even
smarter see exactly how on the cloud
blog the demand for running
containerized workloads in the cloud
keeps growing and so has the need for
people with the relevant skills with our
architecting with google kubernetes
engine specialization you can gain the
skills to run kubernetes and deploy
production services on it using Google
cloud platform and roll on your journey
today last week we shared a solution on
how to plan your cloud migration today
we have a new solution specifically for
migrating to bigquery from a data
warehouse like Terra data this guide
includes what to consider when planning
and sequel references to get you moving
read the details and get migrating if
you want to see one more way bigquery
can help you work with your data check
out this blog from Felipe Hoffa on
geolocation the sample walks you through
new bigquery features and D identifying
IP addresses protecting your data is now
faster and easier to do than ever thanks
for the breakdown Felipe if you want to
read more about these announcements or
even see a full list check out the link
below have any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you